one guy who won't be playing in the
nfl's 100 season at least not at the
beginning of it Rob Gronkowski it had
been teased for a week or two that his
announcement regarding the next chapter
in his career would be coming on Tuesday
and it came and he's going to be a CBD
oil pitchman and he's gonna try to get
the NFL to take CBD oil off the list of
banned substances but beyond the rollout
of this new business venture by Gronk he
talked about some things that requires
some careful attention and thought
especially in light of the Andrew Luck
retirement Chris the first thing we're
gonna play Rob Gronkowski at a press
conference yesterday explaining why he
walked away and he sounds a lot like
Andrew Luck when he reflects on the the
reality of the wear and tear of being a
football player he was Gronk from
Tuesday
want to be clear to my fans I needed to
recover I was not in a good place so
football was bringing me down and I
didn't like it and I was losing that joy
in life like the joy I'm sorry right now
but oh hey let me I really was and I was
fighting through it and I knew what I
signed up for and I knew what I was
fighting through and I knew I just have
to fix myself you know we rarely if ever
have seen that kind of emotion from Rob
Gronkowski as oh I've always marveled at
his ability to retain that enthusiasm
that kind of over-the-top goofiness even
though he's had injury after injury and
surgery after surgery he never got jaded
he never got cynical but Chris he got to
the point where he had enough and that
emotion I think tells us everything we
need to know he just decided at this
point he cannot do it well yes it's just
it's real in the NFL and you know some
guys can can battle through it other
guys it wears on you and when you have
an injury you know history and laundry
list of injuries like Rob Gronkowski you
said it you know in the first hour he's
like operation I mean he truly is I mean
if we looked at it it's unreal how many
things he's had surgery on same with
Andrew Luck to where you know think
about it
yourself in his shoes not only you're
getting up in the morning you're going
oh gosh I can barely walk to the
bathroom and take my first pee of the
morning and you know you're starting to
get going and you can't everything's
hurting yeah I had to throw it out there
cuz that's the first thing you do in the
morning when you're a man okay and
you're getting in the car and you're
going oh my gosh I can barely get in
there yes what do you want to say well I
look I haven't done extensive research
on this I think it's also the first
thing you do in the morning when you're
a woman as well well yes yes yes
my wife certainly does I know that yes
okay I'll be glad to hear that either
way but then think about feeling like
that okay and now you're going and okay
now you got to practice football you're
going like holy crap I can't I could
barely get in my car today I'm gonna
practice so Paul or you're not doing any
football at all and you're just
constantly rehabbing and rehabbing and
rehabbing and then anytime I hear not in
a good place or a dark place I start to
think about opioids you know you're
taking things to make your body feel
better
okay the vicodins of the world and the
anti-inflammatories also that mess with
your stomach and do all these other
issues to where you know it can just
wear on you as in a whole really and I
understand where a guy like Gronk's
coming from and for Gronk there was one
specific injury that he suffered in what
would be at least for now his final NFL
game he spoke at length about the injury
how he reacted to it and how he dealt
with it in the weeks following the
conclusion of the 2018 season here's
more from Gronk on that quad injury
suffered in Super Bowl 53 in the Super
Bowl about a couple minutes into the
second quarter
I caught a pass on the left side cut
over the linebacker took me right out
right here in my quad I flipped in the
air and I knew my quad was was done but
I knew I knew is it was right there and
then I was like last game Super Bowl
game just give it all you have so you
know the game went on everything and I
got done with the game I
could barely walk now I could barely
walk I'm at the after party I go to half
the party like this I sit down and I'm
just chillin all day like the rest of
the night till like 3:00 a.m. I try to
go to bed I sucked for five minutes at
night I couldn't even think I was in
tears in my bed after his Super Bowl
victory it did make that much sense to
me but man for four weeks I couldn't
even sleep for more than 20 minutes of
night after a Super Bowl win then I was
like damn like this sucks like it didn't
feel good man yeah I mean look it gives
you an idea what these guys have a lot
of tear still yeah and here's the hit he
took a little second quarter of the
Super Bowl and he knew you know but yeah
when you know it's your last game you
want to go out on top you do it and you
suck it up and and look he he no I think
he knew at the time he had it it's not
gonna get any better you fight through
it and you're gonna have those weeks of
pain sleeping 20 minutes a night and and
look with all that said guys deal with
that all the time and when they feel
better they forget about it and they
decide they want to come back and play
but we need to be more sensitive to this
cycle that that most if not all NFL
players deal with where you have the
injury you have the pain you have the
surgery you have the recovery you bust
your butt to get yourself back to the
point where you can go play and you go
back and play and you accept the reality
that you're probably gonna be right back
there again and then the cycle continues
and it's amazing that you can shut that
out and embrace and welcome the reality
that you're gonna be right back in that
dark place again yeah dealing with an
injury yeah he wants to play football I
think that's why he's so emotional you
know when he's sitting up there I mean
first off he wasn't just sucking it up
in that game he's been sucking it up for
the last six years of his life I mean
that's really what he's been doing
elbows backs plates and certain body
parts I mean he's got it all going on
he's been dealing with everything and I
think there was a little bit of a
culmination of why you saw him so
emotional is because he knows he loves
football
but he also knows like wow III just
everything took its toll on me and I
lost my love of the foot of football and
because he's just warned about surviving
on a daily basis and that's just a hard
way to live and I'm just you know I'm
glad that I think people are getting a
little inside look after Andrew Luck and
this just to what it takes at times to
get through an NFL season this sport is
more brutal than ever I know people go
all well there's more rules to protect
than ever before but I don't give a damn
baloney okay the world has changed guys
play defensive end in eighth grade and
they don't do anything else and they
play defensive end until the end of time
they don't play basketball they don't
play baseball they don't even play
another position than football they just
go I'm a defense in and that's all they
work on and they lift weights and they
run 40s and they'd get their nutrition
and the game has become so physical and
fast and violent because everybody has
become so specialized in the sport that
yes the rules might be easier than back
in my dad's day or even early in my
career but the game now is is as violent
as it's ever been because there's more
specimens on the field on a week-to-week
basis and with all that said the
specimen who is Rob Gronkowski still not
closing the door on retirement and Chris
yesterday what he said the closest
indication yet that it truly is not over
for Rob Gronkowski here he is yesterday
on the question of whether he will play
football again if I have the desire to
play football again if I feel passionate
about football again if I'm feeling like
I need to be out there on the field I
will go back to football but as of right
now that is not the case it could be the
case in six months it could be the case
in two years it could be the case in
three years it could be the case in
three months but I truly don't see it in
a foreseeable future in like a week or a
month and I'm gonna keep
No you know he started racking up the
various possible timelines it could be
the case in six months it could be the
case in two years it could be the case
in three years and then he throws in it
could be in three months right that's
the one to watch crisp yeah that's what
we said all along September rolls around
he sees the six banner get raised he
sees football move on without him he
sees other guys out there doing what he
used to do and he starts thinking man oh
boy I kind of missed this
yeah and you know some point in October
he starts putting the weight back on
some point around Halloween Tom Brady
gives him a call and says boy we could
really use you some point before
Thanksgiving Gronk is back I I feel like
it's all lining up for that to happen
and we shouldn't be surprised when it
does I know Mike I mean I think I was
with you all the way there and I'm still
I don't you know I think it's certainly
a possibility but I think after seeing
that press conference and him talking
there I think it's gonna be a full year
out at least I do
I just think still in his mind the
misery of pain and the dealing with the
injuries and everything is still gonna
be too fresh to where I hear you he
might have the itch but I think that's
gonna weigh too heavily on him him
remembering right after the Super Bowl
last year and some of the things to wear
it's not quite a raced out of his memory
yet to where he goes okay I'm ready let
me get out there and get playing
football again I used to be like you but
I think it's gonna be at least one year
but I think if he can fast forward
through the regular season and yeah to
the games that matter right he's got
until the Tuesday after week 13 to
unretire you know you reduce and I say
this all the time with quarterbacks
don't take hits because every hit you
take increases the likelihood that that
next it's going to be the one that
injures you well if you can reduce the
total number of hits you take in the
season because you didn't play the first
10 games then you come out and you let
it go and you're pursuing that
immortality it comes with getting the
other hey when they've dead getting that
ring has to be euphoria for the players
right especially the Patriots players
that's the only day of the year you're
allowed to have fun other than the night
after you win the Super Bowl
the night you get the ring
those are the only two occasions out of
365 days 366 in the leap year that
you're allowed to have fun so I think
the lure of yelling that again getting
another ring and getting the Patriots
number seven they want not they won't
say it publicly they want number seven
badly because that puts them past the
Steelers and in first place all-time and
and I I'm not gonna be surprised if
especially if they sputter with the guys
they have a tight end and they quite
likely will Tom Brady makes that phone
call and it's basically like putting the
bat-signal in the air Gronk's gonna be
back yeah will say I don't know if I
feel as strongly about it now but either
way he does have three rings I
understand what you're saying getting
two for special regardless you're right
about the euphoria of the ring it's my
it was my dream in life I didn't care if
I had a you know clean cleats or hold a
clipboard or go work in a cubby hole in
New England I wanted a Super Bowl ring
badly in my life so I can certainly
understand you know the drive to get it
hey you gave an internal organ for the
quest for a splint alright somebody sent
me a ring then damn it let's go
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports